greetings everyone welcome uh
thesis day it's so exciting i've been at
mit since 2012 and i've been to a fair
number of these and it's always exciting
so glad to see you all here
um we have people coming in and out
throughout the day both in person and
via zoom
um
and uh again thank you all for coming
we're gonna stick to a really rigorous
schedule you can see the clock in the
back of the room might be helpful i
think it's about one minute fast but
that's okay um so each presenter will go
for 20 minutes and then it will have 10
minutes of q a and then a super quick
change over to the next presenter um and
we'll be breaking for uh lunch at one
o'clock
so our first presenter today is marvez
and the title of their uh
thesis is controversial science
argumentation skills for teachers in the
digital clinical simulation discussion
leader
take it away
thank you heather
i will share my screen
okay
can't do anything about the bar on the
bottom hope you
uh hello everyone my name is marves i'm
a graduate student in comparative media
studies and in the teaching systems lab
and today i'll be talking about
simulation i designed my thesis
designed to help teachers practice
leading controversial discussions on
issues with their students before they
actually go and implement this lesson
and i focus on the ethics of gene
therapy
so why are facilitated controversial
discussions in schools so important um i
as a first year student teacher i was 19
i was in an 11th and 12th grade ap
english classroom and some of the
students were the same age as me and in
that classroom my mentor teacher i work
with cared a lot about debate um he did
this one exercise where i believe
students write a bunch of pro and con
articles about recycling and for obvious
reasons all the students were pro
recycling
and then he took on the con perspective
and argued one against 20 against all
the students and being 19 brand new
teacher i thought that was both really
exciting and terrifying and i'll be
really interested in controversial
discussions a lot of people think
controversial discussions are only a
like social studies or a history class
type of activity but i think it's
important to do in all the subjects and
the subject i focus on for this
simulation is um gene therapy right here
at mit we are designing the gene
therapies of the future from
new mrna technologies uh just recently
in the most recent issue of science
we've learned that a consortium of
scientists have almost completely
sequenced the human genome
and we're also having difficult
conversations about who should be the
stewards of the human race when we
design new gene therapies we're deciding
where humanity will go and so i think
that these discussions are really
important for high school students to
have to be the next generation of
researchers designers and innovators
and i'm going to come back to these
research questions later but i would
like to briefly mention them here i'm
interested in mostly two things how can
we increase teachers comfort in leading
controversial discussions through a
simulation and through this simulation
can we study the teacher dialogue
choices that they make and how those
might different from those with
different levels of speaking experience
so this is a brief agenda of what i'm
going to look at today i'm mostly
focused on chapter three and chapter
four which is my methodology and the
results
so first i would like to introduce a
couple problems of practice in teaching
education first is that teacher
candidates rarely have the opportunity
just to practice one element by them by
itself and they're evaluated on their
ability to combine all aspects of
teaching at once this is just parts of
the massachusetts rubric for assessing
student features and as you can see
there's a lot of things in just this one
bullet point that teachers faces
additionally for classroom controversy a
lot of teachers report that there are
significant challenges to them teaching
controversial issues such as a lack of
comfort concern about pushback from
parents administration and their job
security and a lack of instruction on
how to teach controversial topics
even
despite these challenges teachers report
a strong desire for academic freedom in
their classrooms and they believe that
teaching controversies are critical to
democratic citizenship
we know that the classroom is one of the
few places where students hear ideas
outside of their ideological bubble so
we really need to foster this type of
environment
so if teachers comfort level is a strong
predictor of whether they even engage in
classroom discussions this becomes
before they plan to do a discussion with
their students and they actually
implement it when they do implement it
there are some elements of a good
discussion that can be practiced such as
enforcing classic norms
and there's also recent challenges that
have become a lot more difficult over
the past few years such as where does
the teacher's opinion belong in a
discussion and how can a teacher manage
misinformation
and so it is on these four topics that i
see that there's an opportunity to
design simulations not only do you need
a skill at leading difficult discussions
you need to rehearse your knowledge on
the topic enforce classroom norms and
also work on your digital literacy
skills with your students to combat
misinformation and this is where we have
the opportunity to improve the practice
of improvisational interactions that
we'll see in the simulation by later
so for at least the last 60 years we've
been working on the difficult problem of
getting teachers to practice um
difficult elements of teaching um in
different technologies and mediums in
1962 curse describes the clashing
simulator which is a projection
environment which a teacher would stand
in front of a projector watch some
classroom moments and then um a panel of
experts would decide if the teacher
responded appropriately and cue up the
next video sequence what was interesting
about this from the 60s is that you had
to do it correct if you didn't do it
right they would make you do it over and
over again
and in the 70s to 90s with the rise of
um home computing we see a lot more um
computer games for teaching
for teaching
teachers how to balance lots of
classroom tasks all at once
what i'm affectionately calling tsl at
all from 2019 or 2018 to today is this
one called teacher moments which is a
digital platform to create simulations
about teacher education especially in
topics of equity and around difficult
elements of teaching in teacher moments
you can do linear scenarios branching
scenarios like i will describe here
and use audio text and ai back in to
capture data
and i would like to talk about
specifically the evolution of the
discussion leader suite and discussion
leader is a type of practice space
specifically designed to help
practice
leading a controversial discussion our
original version was a linear
implementation made in google slides
where you would type in what you say and
no matter what you said
the simulation progressed the same way
about immigration policy and then we
eventually moved to twine which is a
choose run adventure game engine um
where we created this branching math uh
branching path model again about
immigration policy with over 100 paths
and about um 12 different endings um
this is due to a lot of the feedback and
iteration we got from play tests from
people who are like i want this to be
more responsive to me and then in our
twine implementation we only had three
or four students in every scenario and
we were told that try to get as many
students as you can so we thought about
how can we get as many student voices in
this discussion as possible without
making it too computationally complex
so with teacher moments being able to
take in branching path models we're able
to have 20 different student voices in
our discussions and we piloted one
version about freedom of speech in a
move and then the current implementation
i'm talking about today is a branching
path model on gene editing ethics this
one has over four million paths uh 21 to
the fifth possible options and the
structured challenges centered around
the elements of a good discussion five
different student groups you speak with
and at each group the difficulty gets
harder and there's a different skills
practice
so i'd like to bring up our research
questions again i'm really interested in
how we can improve people's comfort and
we do this through a self-report survey
and then looking at the teacher dialogue
choices and how they differ by analyzing
the paths
there's a box around this um
so in the simulation participants take
on the role of a high school biology
teacher near the end of a genetics unit
they're told that students have read two
opposing articles for homework one about
cystic fibrosis treatments and one about
editing embryos and they're um
discussing this broader question if
genetic modification treatments in
humans should be allowed to what and why
and so they have a cost of 20 students
into five groups of four and each group
focuses on a different skill that i will
show in the next couple of times
um and these also align with the
massachusetts state standards for high
school science so this is an actual
lesson that you could teach with your
high school students
so the simulation flow is that the
participants see the same introduction
that i just gave you i collect some data
and some demographic information and
then they enter they answer some
anticipate questions about the possible
discussion strategies they are going to
utilize
and then for the five groups they speak
to the student group and make different
dialogue places reflect and then they
reflect on the simulation as a whole
so these are the five skills i'm having
teachers practice during the simulation
uh and these are in order of increasing
difficult personalized practice asking
probing questions not asking these
simple yes or no
group two focuses on exploration versus
telling um students in this group want
you to want the teacher to give them the
answer so how do you work through the
problem with students
the third group is practicing whether to
disclose a personal opinion to students
the fourth one is having very low
engagements and how do you work with
students and the fifth one is working on
digital information with your students
this is a visualization of just um what
one path could be like through group one
on the left you see the original bit of
student dialogue that participants will
see and they make some teacher dialogue
choice they get new dialogue they make
another choice they get new dialogue and
make their final choice and they get a
final bit of student dialogue that acts
as a bit of feedback for them for how
they did in the scenario
and i'm going to be representing these
paths that people make using these tree
diagrams everyone starts at the black
start node and then based on their first
level decision is put into one of these
possible 21 paths
and this is what it could look like for
someone who goes through all five groups
and how they end up on different paths
but go through all of them in the same
order
so i got 42 people to participate in
this experiment there are undergraduate
and graduate education students of
fellows in the community the teacher
program high school teachers and college
professors and i'm interested in
stratifying the data out by how many
years of teaching experience people had
and there was a pretty good spread
between
non-teachers novice teachers and expert
teachers and 50 of participants reported
that they had previously led a
controversial discussion in the past
so for my first research question i'm
really interested in this change of
comfort i asked at the beginning and the
end of the scenario how comfortable are
you with leading a controversial just
and there was an increase from 2.95 to
3.69 and this is a significant change we
can see in the delta column here that we
got a lot of people out of slightly
uncomfortable and a lot of people up
into slightly comfortable
and then when we stratify this out by
years of experience we see that everyone
goes up um the more than five only goes
up slightly which is expected for
teachers already really confident uh
with their students and their material
the greatest gain was for those with
less than five years of teaching
experience whole point of 1.5
i think that was really great because
even if you're a novice teacher with one
or two years of experience that's still
a lot of teaching experience so how can
we just get you comfortable with
teaching controversial issues in your
classroom
so now i'm going to go through each of
the five groups and the first level
choices that people made and how
this is and how these are different
based on their years of experience so in
the first group the participant
approaches the table it's an easy
growing group of four students and
they're having a calm discussion and all
you have to do is practice asking
open-ended questions
you can these are the three levels of
choices that people could make they
could ask an open-ended question a
limited open-ended question or a closed
question
and we see that those with less teaching
experience were more likely to uh start
the conversation with a closed question
and those with more teaching experience
were most likely to begin the
conversation with the most open-ended
question
i'm also going to be showing for each of
the groups the most common paths that
people went on path 35 and past 36 were
the most common here but for those with
more than five years of teaching
experience 36 was the most common so
what is the difference between these two
paths there's only these are the same
except for the last uh final dialogue
choice in path 35
these participants told the group it
seems like they have more to discuss and
you leave them to check on the next
group but for fact path 36 favored by
those with more experience you ask the
you ask another open-ended question to
the student so i think this is an
interesting um
teacher dialogue choice by experience
for group two this is about student
directed discussion the students have a
technical question to ask you that you
know the answer to but um you can choose
to give them the answer or let them
figure it out for themselves
and we can see here that the those again
with
more than five years of teaching
experience we're much less likely to do
the teacher direct
option and we're more likely to do
student directed or a prior knowledge
question
and for this one the participants were
much more spread out over the simulation
with lots of paths being favored
especially in the no experience group
path 27 was pretty common but what was
interesting is that the participants
were zero teaching experience none of
them utilized path 27 and they actually
made choices that caused them to leave
the discussion early and move on to the
next group
for group three the students are have
you get to the table it's described as
being loud they're having a very excited
debate and they want to know the
teacher's opinion so you can share your
opinion decline to share or ask them
what they first
and we see that only those with no
experience outright declined to share
the initial part and those with more
teaching experience 22 percent of
participants actually shared their
opinion as the first choice
a path 31 was the most common for these
participants and in this one you asked
the group for their opinion first
declined to share your opinion again and
then you they sort of asked this one
student who's been playing devil's
advocate the whole time if they have a
different take on the issue
only um 29 of participants ever chose to
share their opinion on genetic editing
with the group
in the um
anticipate section we asked participants
what they thought about teacher opinion
and this was very rarely mentioned
and of participants to reach an
opportunity to reinforce classroom norms
to keep students from talking over each
other 93 percent uh chose to do so
in group four this group is not
participating at all and you notice that
one of the students has actually gone to
the bathroom during the discussion so
you can start with an open participation
a more disciplinary statement or
summarize what other students said
and we see that only those with no
experience take the disciplinary track
but those with any teaching experience
has sort of even split between an open
participation question or summarizing
what others have said
past 15 remained uh was the most common
for group four
and it's to ask the group what they
discuss as a whole ask one student what
she thinks and then ask others if they
agree
um in the scenario there's a moment
where um the student who's missing comes
back from the bathroom and actually only
two participants of 13 um even engage
with that student at all i think is
really interesting
and then for the misinformation group
yes this group again is described as
another loud excited group um they're
having a lively debate but you get there
and you realize the article is a piece
of misinformation that you've seen
before
so you can investigate the
misinformation with the students um
deflect or just tell them outright you
already know that's false close your
chromebook let's get back on
um so those with less teaching
experience were more likely to
just shut down the students right at the
beginning and those with more teaching
experience were more likely to say so
where did you get that source from and
that's exactly what we see in the most
common paths of 13 here so path 13 is to
ask drew to explain about the source
that she's showing her group and you
asked the table what organization
published this article you asked you to
search up world daily news report
another tab when you do so you can go to
wikipedia and you see that this is a
satirical website this is the fact
checking seal called lateral reading
which the stanford history education
group has done a lot of research on it's
one of the most powerful
tools we can
use as teachers to get our students to
work through misinformation
so i would um like to reconnect to the
research questions our first point about
comfort we see that this can be a tool
in increasing confidence for each for
leading controversial discussions um all
groups saw an increase and the largest
confidence boost was for novice teachers
again i want to stress that novice
teachers does not mean having any
experience
even new teachers have lots of great
experience and they know their students
and their school and their material so
how can we just get them
ready to teach these controversial
issues
and then for the second research
question about um analyzing the
different moves that people with
different levels of experience make more
experienced participants tended to
selected the choices that allowed the
students to control the debate and those
with less experience were more likely to
ask the teacher-directed question
and by analyzing the common uh teacher
dialogue choices we can show where
teachers diverge in there
i've only showed here what happens at
the first um choice point um i look for
more in my thesis what happens at every
other point
um in the future i would love to be able
to expand the possible teacher dialogue
choices based on participant feedback
um i asked participants in the scenario
was there anything you wanted to do in
the scenario that was not an option for
you we got a lot of great results from
that so taking their feedback
integrating it in and giving them more
options that are more authentic to their
experience and also working on
generative response student dialogue
using something like a bert model
trained on student discussions would be
great in which everyone sees the same
starting piece of student dialogue you
type in your response
it's analyzed by nlp methods and then it
generates a completely novel new um
student dialogue for you to respond
the simulation i designed for my thesis
is already very replayable there's lots
of different paths but i think it would
be really interesting to develop
something that's completely novel every
time you play it
and finally this was my original thesis
idea that got cut down by covid doing a
v test in classrooms where people would
complete the simulation and then have
teachers implement this lesson with
their students and compare that against
a no simulation control group with the
same lesson and analyze are the dialogue
choices different between those teachers
and those students
and now i would like to do some
acknowledgments
obviously people funded this thanks
the teaching systems lab the
graduate program in cms and the nsf
graduate research fellowship program
um the teaching systems lab because i've
been here for four years and i'm going
to cry
since my first like conference and you
know to presenting my master's thesis
today and you know my friends and family
this is the only photo i could find of
the cms cohort on zoom
so we have to take a good one today um
you know everyone who's helped me on my
thesis ideas and for grad school so
thank you everyone i'll now take
questions
yeah so we definitely see in like um
discussion themed teacher literature
that this is like one of the biggest
things to having a productive discussion
it's really hard to let the students go
off and have their own ideas with each
other like in a socratic seminar because
you're afraid or what if someone says
something inflammatory or what if it
completely goes off the rails so that's
why establishing um these norms early
with your students and co-creating these
norms i think is really important to
foster in a classroom environment where
you feel comfortable enough as a teacher
where it's like that will not happen and
if it does my students are responsible
enough to pause in the discussion and
return to norms
implementation and how accumulations
like this uh
end up being used how they get into the
training programs and then uh
where they
i mean i i guess uh does one expect
these controversial issues to be
discussed in general would you expect
more private schools to be interested in
something like this the public schools
because it's you know obviously um
there are plenty of school districts
that are
would like to have no controversial
discussion whatsoever in the classroom
and so how do you tackle that issue
which is political and is outside of
your research in many ways and yet
impacts like the implementation of all
the work that you've done yeah that's a
good question um one of the things the
teaching systems lab has done is um
hosted moocs on for teacher training
about different um equity issues and
embedded the simulations within them um
also the teacher moments platform is
like free and open source so if you're
really curious you could go and do this
simulation right now but i think the
dissemination is a really um interesting
problem because like you said a lot of
laws are currently being passed that
keep
teachers from talking about
controversial issues in the classroom so
how can we um you know work with those
teachers to still make sure that they
are meeting their students needs of
being able to have democratic dialogue
justin
[Music]
[Music]
difference from both the design point of
view and then kind of
yeah so we saw that on
like groups of five and three had the
most convergence and group two was all
over the place and so it is interesting
consider was this a design artifact did
i as the designer make the answer too
obvious for some people or are people
really experimenting and trying out lots
of different things um in their path so
um in my thesis in the write-up i will
explore further about like was this
actually an artifact of the design or
are people making these sort of novel
interests
josh
what type of feedback so mentioned
what type of feedback
would you want to give people as they
were going to the different
oh yes uh so josh asks what types of
feedback would i give to participants in
this simulation so one of the
anticipation questions that participants
saw was um exactly the same scenario
from five it says
uh you
you get to a discussion and you notice
that students are discussing a piece of
misinformation as if it's true and you
already know that it's misinformation
what will you do and a lot of the
responses that people said was i would
talk to them after class or i would
ignore it not a lot of confronting it in
the moment so that's a piece where i
would love to be able to give some
feedback to people
oh it looks like you might have said
that you would have waited until after
the discussion to talk with the student
but it's actually really important to
confront this information when it
happens that would be a great moment um
to give feedback to people
thomas
thank you very much
[Music]
uh yeah so how could like
um civic engagement like
uh people who work in schools use these
type of tools
do you think there's something specific
or do you think this is different
oh okay yeah thank you tomas asked if
there could if this platform is specific
to schools or could be used in other
areas i do think that this design could
be used in other areas to encourage on
discussions like um not only in the
civic field but in lots of different
areas and politics and other
controversial issues
just my interest is in education but i
do think it could be used in many
different places to prepare people to
have controversial discussions
and one of the things that i'm curious
about because you can see all the
answers is there a perfect path
through the simulation did anybody take
that perfect path
and then the the corollary of this is um
it seems like there are some right
answers and there aren't some right
answers can you explain a little bit
about how you design
yeah thank you meredith meredith asked
are there any right answers through this
simulation um i did not design any path
to be specifically like the prime path
like this is the optimal solution
because with the replayability of
simulations i wanted people to be able
to go back and explore different um
methods they could take with their
students so there's not necessarily a
right answer there's things that sort of
engage students more but no matter what
you pick the discussion does it sort of
shut down and end horribly in the
original version of discussion leader i
did have that actually where the
students would stop talking and your
classroom descended into chaos but
participants told me that was not
conducive to their learning surprisingly
so i took that out so it's really more a
tool like exploration of different
skills
um you so much thank you everyone